just curious how many of you have seen
that that that lecture on YouTube from
2013 anyone here a few of you where any
of you here in person at Stanford you
were it was December I think December
5th of June that was a that was a
special day
not because of the lecture because what
the PBOC did or for Bitcoin in China so
I'll talk about about that as well
great so good to be back good to be back
at Stanford it's changed so much I was
walking around I've almost forgotten
where the buildings are and all that so
how many of you are active students
enrolled at Stanford okay good and alums
a lot of alums awesome and the most
important question of how many of you
are fans of Bitcoin to actually own some
Bitcoin no matter how small amounts oh
wow okay a lot good good okay so I'm
here to talk about what's next for
Bitcoin and blockchain in China I'll
talk about Bitcoin as well so we have I
think ninety minutes right or eighty
minutes is that right okay perfect so
and it will also save some time for Q&A
afterwards okay let's get started that's
one of the first original Bitcoin logos
from 2000 I think 2008 2009 the new ones
have it slightly different okay so so
what's next for for Bitcoin and
blockchain in China do you guys know any
quick answers is there a future for
Bitcoin and blockchain in China you're
here to find out so I I don't pretend to
know the answers but I'll give you my
perspective on it so China is actually
crazy about crypto as you know for the
last five six years China has been crazy
about crypto a lot of trading a lot of
activities and I'll tell you about how
that's been okay so obviously with the
recent crackdown so let me let me take a
step back so it's been crazy about
crypto for the last five seven years but
last year specifically 2017 China
suffered a big blow the industry
suffered a big blow because the PBOC
sort of forced all the exchanges to
close down
so in light of all the I cos last summer
so they formally asked all the exchanges
closed down or it was a more informally
rather so BTC China we closed down our
Chinese women be exchange in September
October of last year and many many
Bitcoin crypto companies exchanges have
sentences closed down and they've moved
offshore and so on but the question is
what is the future so assuming that you
know about this brief history what is
the future and the futures actually
continues to be more Bitcoin crypto
mining and it's still happening a lot in
China it's still because China still has
a subsequent China still has a very
large share of the global market share
for crypto mining and the reason is that
it comes down to economics it comes down
to people in China have the resources
have the hardware have electricity and
they can make money with it so that's
why it's very very popular so for the
uninitiated what is Bitcoin mining are
you guys curious about what big Bitcoin
mining is anyone who doesn't know should
I just skip the slide looks like you
guys don't know so Bitcoin mining is
like a free lottery so you get these
Bitcoin by doing computations for the
blockchain okay why is it popular in
China a combination of they have good
assembly for electronics they have good
chip design and also the electricity's
is cheap and sometimes even free so we
can talk about that later about the
regulation so more crypto trading so
even though crypto trading has
officially been stopped in China there's
still a lot of underground exchanges
underground peer-to-peer trading so
crypto trading is still quite popular in
China they won't talk about it there's a
lot of you know just basically a lot of
things are just person-to-person
underground so not institutionalized
groups are trading but but certainly
crippled trading for speculators and
investors alike so come down to two
things okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna ask a
throw this question to the audience so
you have invest in investment investing
which is like savings okay and then you
also have speculation okay which is like
earning money right it's like it's like
earnings making money so what's the
difference
kay guys give me a good answer
on how can you tell when something is
done as investment versus it's done as a
speculation research okay what else
research that's a good answer right time
horizon what else risk profile what else
anything else those are all great
answers but turns out everything you've
said from research to time horizon to
risk profile it's in the end it's all
subjective right
has anyone purchased real estate in the
Bay Area recently right if you know for
those of you who have or even in China
Shanghai or anywhere you know the buyer
probably thinks is a good investment but
someone's standing aside we're thinking
that's that's really really speculative
now given the bubble and so on and so
forth so it turns out it's all
subjective so my point is that even
though we all have our own standards
what is an investment
what is speculation the fact of the
matter is someone else who's doing it
you might perceive as speculation when
they themselves wholeheartedly believe
it's an investment and vice versa for
example I honestly tell people I've been
investing in Bitcoin and what do you
think Warren Buffett would say he'd say
like Bobby's speculating now I haven't
had this conversation with him but but
chances are he would say that I'm
speculating so it's all - perspective
okay so and then we have the third term
which is gambling so when you're
speculating people think you're gambling
right so it's a sliding scale it's all
subjective so what it is not so I'm
going to jump around different topics
okay so in China Bitcoin is not about
evading capital controls that's the most
common misconception people think that
China where people know that China has
strict foreign capital controls and
people assume that people use Bitcoin to
evade all the capital controls the
reality is that in China if you've been
to China anyone who's been or lived or
studied or visited or if you know on
your trip to China you may run into this
the official way to change money's going
to the bank line up it literally takes
at least 45 to half 45 minutes in one
hour to exchange money US dollar to
Chinese women being back and forth
anyways it's hugely inefficient I'll say
that and then they have these so-called
underground money changers where you can
just change money
the street really easily US dollars any
currency to remain be back and forth so
and then that's for in person and
there's there's the sort of online
platforms and so on so there's a lot of
ways to do it
underground fashion so people rarely
actually use Bitcoin for capital
controls for conversion okay
people may may may use it as an
investment but it's rarely used for
capital T V capital controls and I'll
show you an example okay I'll give you a
analogy so this is a photo I darkened it
of an airport happens to be Fort
Lauderdale Airport so the question is
their capital flight right so how many
of you let's let's take a quick show of
hands how many of you actually believe
that people in China or had the idea
that people in China would use Bitcoin
to evade capital controls and for
capital flight anyone yes a few people
have you done it yourself I'll call you
out by name okay so so the analogy the
example is this okay ten million roaming
B which is about one and a half million
US dollars so if someone you know rich
person wanted to bring that out of China
and they would they would use 10 million
remain being to buy Bitcoin okay this
was this was easy to do back before 2007
its 2017 the closure of the exchanges so
now it's harder to do but you could do
it right and then you would then bring
the Bitcoin to an exchange abroad in
Europe in the United States and sell it
for US dollar and euro right so have you
invaded capital controls well yeah sort
of but but the reality is that what's
happening is there's also capital ending
because the Bitcoin actually arrived
into the exchange before you bought it
right it's a bit kind of come from
somewhere as an exchange we didn't just
fatally create the Bitcoin for you to
purchase right so the Bitcoin came from
someone who want to sell it and the
seller actually now after you bought it
the seller would now have the 10 million
remain be you follow me so in the end
it's actually trade neutral and no
effect on the foreign capital reserve
the foreign reserves of the country
and this is a very important point even
central bankers misunderstand this point
so for every trade that's trade on the
Bitcoin exchange for all the money that
gets turned into Bitcoin equivalently at
the same time magically the Bitcoin for
the seller becomes the money so the
money actually stays in the country and
this is a very important point the money
all stays in the country so for the two
people yes individually perspective some
someone was able to change the buyer was
able to change their ten million or
maybe two Bitcoin it doesn't matter the
price by the way also there's a very key
point it doesn't matter what price
Bitcoin is whether it's a five hundred
maybe or fifty thousand where maybe
where it is today you could still get
some number of bitcoins with the 10
million renminbi but the seller would
have then sold their position it could
be one seller it could be a thousand
sellers and they would now have either
the whole ten million or a fraction than
the ten million you follow me so the
money stays in the banking system the US
dollar that's in the China foreign
reserves did not move anywhere right it
doesn't matter if it's u.s. dollars your
euros or gold nothing moved
it's just that Bitcoin came in and out
and then the money change hands so
that's why I use this photo of the
airport because it's kind of like people
getting paranoid oh my gosh all the all
the planes are taking out taking off out
of San Francisco Airport every day oh my
gosh we have a huge you know exodus of
airplanes but the reality is for every
ten airplanes that take off from San
Francisco Airport guess what
ten airplanes landed in the morning well
maybe sometimes nine sometimes eleven
but you get the point so the air Airport
itself over a long series of time is net
neutral in terms of number of airplanes
you guys follow me yeah okay so for
those of you who care about this topic
that's my explanation so so bitcoin is
really money in the cloud okay this is
this is for the Chinese people like for
globally alike okay money in the cloud
it's a digital asset essentially in my
opinion
bitcoin is the ultimate hard currency
okay for someone like me living abroad
and unlike those you who live in the
United States you don't care much about
hard currencies but all into globally
people all around the world care very
much about hard currencies because their
local currencies generally are not have
not stood the test of time okay what you
know where there's an African country
European country
you know Asian country so hard currency
is very important in the rest of the
world and Bitcoin in my opinion is the
ultimate hard currency even though
there's nothing solid about it okay so
so to summarize a little bit bitcoin is
about investing in the future it's about
investing in the future with the
internet with blockchain future
technologies it's a notion that before
2008 before 2009 all of commerce all of
transactions payments were done using
this thing called fiat money and gold
right these are all physical you know
assets right physical assets and
accounting as assets but nothing was
digital you know you know as I've grown
up I've seen the revolution of digital
photography you know entertainment
movies music all going digital now you
have a lot of services going digital but
money and finance is probably the last
frontier so this is really about money
assets going digital for the first time
okay so it's a new revolutionary global
asset class I emphasize is truly truly
global because Bitcoin has no boundaries
no language barriers no cultural
barriers no gender preferences nothing
it's anything anyone your pets can own
Bitcoin your machines can your washing
machine can own Bitcoin you can own
Bitcoin okay so yeah it's a new digital
asset for digital age okay that's what
bitcoin is about so now let's let's talk
about prices anyone care about prices
this supposed to be academic audience so
only only few of you so that that's
about right in other conference I go to
like everyone and yeah we all care about
prices that's all we care about good
corn prices do you guys know what
Bitcoin price is today anyone know right
now 9000 how much nine oh six nine
thousand yeah yeah I have all my watch I
do I do I'm an Apple watch the bottom
line is is the live Bitcoin price yeah
I've had it for the last few years okay
so we're gonna talk about beef a brief
history of Bitcoin in China historically
if BTC China on that through looking at
Bitcoin prices okay so when it's a trip
down
memory lane if you will unfortunately
our memory lane only starts it only goes
back seven years it starts in June of
2011 that's because that's when we first
established the very first Bitcoin
exchange in China called
BTC China so I I joined this come
this team my co-founders in 2013 but
they started in June of 2011 and this
was a first Bitcoin exchange in China
and the reason it got started reporters
asked me why did I start this exchange
and I said it was simple because Chinese
people wanted to buy and sell Bitcoin
and at the time the only other exchange
in the world was the famous MT GOx
exchange mount Cox and that was in Japan
Tokyo and unfortunately for Chinese
people it was actually quite hard to get
money into empty or get money out
so my co-founders decided to start BTC
China to provide a local platform and
back then it was very intrusive website
it was just all personal accounts moving
money so it's very it is the fun days
the easy fun days where where anyways so
yeah my co-founders we just use a
personal accounts to move money and to
accept deposits and withdrawals and all
that so those are very early days and
because very early days because it's
really cheap guess how much it was it
started at the first train I believe is
that 100 RMB and by the way the skills
are in RMB okay the the conversion ratio
is about 6.2 or 6.3 RMB per US dollar so
this would be about 1518 dollars u.s.
okay the red and blue is just high in
the low okay so I didn't have good data
but he was just high and low for the for
the day so as you can tell what happened
was for the first year it started
trading at 100 RMB and it's gone down to
as low as about 14 or 11 I forgot I was
11 about 11 or 14 RMB basically 2 bucks
two dollars u.s. and then went back up
by end of 2012 to about about the same
price 180 8200 RMB so if you were in
China you had a chance to buy Bitcoin at
the amazing price of two US dollars per
Bitcoin
right this is about October November of
2011 those are the good days anyone buy
Bitcoin yes yeah what time no not in
this chart okay so I I didn't either
I'll tell you my sad story is I got
involved with Bitcoin right before this
and and I have to blame it on my
computer science degrees because I was
too smart you know and I was too worried
about security and I was like until I
find a good way to store it I'm not
gonna buy a Bitcoin and if I missed it
for like the first two years so that's
that's precisely what happened and I
tell the story because some of you are
probably doing the same thing you I
don't know how to store it so I'm gonna
wait and by 2020 when you get around to
it the price will be higher okay so so
the next slide is the first rally okay
and I witnessed this firsthand it is in
2013 so if you look at this these are
all linear scales and what happens is if
you compress it you know through through
time that that whole sort of you curve
becomes a pretty flat line okay so the
Green Line here is actually the high
range of the previous chart okay so it
comes down here okay so so in in in
February of 2013 that's when I
approached the co-founders to join them
as CEO and to invest in the company and
that's when the rally started run around
there I don't think it's causation it's
just correlation and then and then I
remember talking to my brother about
price yeah this is a distinct memory I
remember talking about brother my
brother Charlie who's also famous I was
like hey what do you think she do a
price break out and he said yeah it's
gonna break out past twenty US dollars
and then it's gonna go up and certainly
right around April I broke up and it
went all the way to about two hundred
and sixty eight dollars u.s. on mt.gox
so in China remain being went to like a
thousand eight hundred or be okay that
was that was April 13th or April 15th I
forgot the exact date and then of course
it came back crashing down by more than
half
okay so let me ask you would this be a
good time to buy it point a or point B
at the peak or point C after the
correction a B or
see yeah all of them that's actually
true because if you think if you're
buying Bitcoin for just a few weeks then
you better buy it at a if you're buying
for four for multiple years like
investment right then then it really
didn't matter and you time well time
will show this so that's the that's a
you and went up went down so that's a
20x increase just in that just a short a
few weeks okay
my necklace the next slide okay so if we
squash it down again the blue line is
the previous line and now we're adding
the rest of 2013 okay after after that
summer it was flat trading around $100
yeah around $150 and and then went up in
November and then another correlation
thing is that's the day when BTC China
announced our venture funding we got
funded Series A funding by Lightspeed
lights me China and the day we're not
suppressed released Bitcoin price just
squared up alright so I don't know if
it's causation of correlation but was
Monday November 17th when I went up and
it kept going up until the PBOC decided
crack it down on December 5th which is
when I was here at Stanford do you guys
remember that was the day I got off the
plane
you know blue who was it was a Bloomberg
or or or what's that the publication
Reuters yeah one of them was calling me
like I was on the plane about to take
off that have you heard what I'm like
what's gonna happen like there attacked
an eye out don't worry going on the
plane came back landed and the price
just crashed so that was those fun days
so basically it went all the way up to
$1,300 okay from from about you know
$150 so that was another u-shaped that
went up and this time it was 4x increase
from the peak from the previous peak
okay
okay so you started to see a pattern
here the U and then the straight up okay
so this is now we look we even go longer
we go through 2016 so this part is all
new this is the second bubble and then
for the for the next three years there's
actually three-year Bitcoin winter from
2014 all the through 2016
of course mt.gox website no I've said
there the whole exchange went bust in
February of 2014 and that was a huge
shaker in the industry any of you have
money and mt.gox any of you yeah you
might get some back I hear is that right
have you got him back yet partially cool
okay so so it was a it was a whole sort
of Bitcoin winter bear market and it
lasted three years these were the the
hardest years for me running the company
it was just gloom and doom there was no
cash flow we're just burning money
people are losing confidence people
leaving and all that stuff so those are
those are the hard winter days ok ok so
so the question is what's gonna happen
after 2016 well well if you follow the
the charts then what happens ok so so
now everything gets squashed down
through this to this green line and this
is what happens after tell 60 it breaks
out in 2017 ok it breaks out from one
the high was one thousand three dollars
and it went all the way to how much yeah
five six thousand dollars if I recall
correctly yeah it's actually went up
even more okay so all these you shapes
and keep going up okay 5x increase okay
so I didn't update this chart to now but
essentially this is where the price
would be right now at about you know
nine thousand US dollars fifty fifty
sixty thousand remain be okay and now
you shrink it down i perfectly shrinked
it down this is the future okay we're in
2018 this is the future so what's gonna
happen so why predict is that you know
it went up to this high by the way it
really did went up to this high this was
in December December 12th of 2017 and
you know we've we come crashing down
you know correction and it might even go
higher so I can only say this this is
this might happen and the question is
will there be a multi-year bear market
or will it happen really fast that I
don't know professor Richard I know
okay okay
so in China bikal was never about
payments and spending okay
in some countries it is in the u.s.
people supposedly
right here they use it to buy illicit
drugs and services right but in China I
mean that stuff is really stamped out so
clamp down so there's none of that
and then in China they don't even allow
it officially even the merchants Alibaba
tapa team all jingdong you know they
officially forbid all transactions
relating to Bitcoin and that's by the
orders of the of the regulator's
government okay so all the payment
companies they don't touch it all the
banks they don't touch it okay what it
is about is about making money in China
bitcoin is very much about making money
it's very much about the entrepreneurial
spirit how to make extra income
investment in trading again you know you
can use it interchangeably in terms of
investment and speculation all right
so um this is the million dollar
question that many people have posed I
don't know if you're curious about this
what do Chinese regulators think about
Bitcoin right very interested yes so
before I answer this I'm gonna I'm gonna
change the question it's act it actually
is not what Chinese regulators think
about it it's actually what global
regulators think about Bitcoin and
there's two reasons then but one reason
is that it turns out the issue is a
global issue it's not a uniquely Chinese
problem do you follow me and the second
reason is the solution is the same the
challenges and the solutions are the
same so that's why very that's very much
why the Chinese regularly themselves
often consult international regulators
to see what they might do so China might
either copy or they might do it first so
there's a lot of global conversation
going on in fact as you may know I
believe it's a g20 they're having
meetings these few months about crypto
so I'm not personally involved but I get
a lot of briefings on that they've been
you know all the g20 countries are
getting together they gotten together I
think in Argentina or recent
forgot where switch South American
country and you know so they're gonna
publish something I think in July
timeframe a global approach to
regulation so it's really much a global
problem okay so now I'm gonna tell you
what the what the problems are so the
global challenges Bitcoin regulation
it's a decentralized currency not a real
currency violates foreign control its
money laundering lack of identity base
use of fraud pyramid schemes also
there's a lot of high hacking security
risk I seal regulation is also topic
corruption graft taxation issues
speculate speculative trading market
crashes and finally its competition with
government crypto so this is the litany
this is the whole laundry list of
everything that's problematic with
Bitcoin alright I challenge you to find
something that's not on this list
alright I mean really all the
regulator's I don't care if it's tax
authorities or stock regulator agency or
banks or central banks or whatever these
are things on top of their mind they
care about this and and to be honest
there is no solution okay so my answer
to you is this the reason bitcoin poses
these challenges is actually in the DNA
of Bitcoin so for those of you who've
sort of read more about Bitcoin
understand it Bitcoin was designed and
invented and created in a certain way to
have certain attributes do you follow me
has certain attributes and these
attributes were not a random collection
from nature they're actually
purposefully injected into Bitcoin by
the Creator right Satoshi Nakamoto okay
in the white paper so as you know as you
may know researchers have been setting
digital currencies for the last ten
years you know decades and they never
came up with the real solution until the
breakthrough in 2008 that's the white
paper Satoshi Nakamoto so with with this
approach which was released in January
2009 this thing called Bitcoin was born
and it was born with these attributes
which flies in the face with traditional
law and enforcement and regulation and
that's why you have all these issues
okay so so to sort of
skip to the end my point is I'm sorry
that's that's how it is you know meaning
for example like lack of lack of real
identity Bitcoin and Bitcoin accounts or
our pseudo anonymous the reason is it's
just an account number right it's just
like a Swiss number account number Swiss
bank number account number do you have
those any one Swiss bank yeah I'll call
the IRS so so same thing right it could
be it could be you know corruption graft
hey I'm sorry you know with Bitcoin
there will always be corruption graft
because you can always send money
through the recipient anonymously and
they could receive it anonymously and
it's here to stay right it's just if you
do with gold but it's just more
convenient with Bitcoin in fact I you
know in China talking to people talking
to law not just China in other countries
as well talking to law enforcement and
agencies they're seeing more and more
instances of politicians and so on
accepting Bitcoin you know as corruption
right graft you know speculative trading
you can't stop it because it's volatile
the price to go up and down people trade
that that's human nature to want to have
short-term profits you know and the
market crash is because of the bubble
and the the over buying and all that so
there's a lot of this human nature a lot
of this is just inherent in Bitcoin not
a real currency well that's that's
that's a label they put on governments
they'd love to do that is it bitcoins
not a real currency don't don't don't
subscribe to it money laundry I mean oh
like money laundering I mean this is
this is key i I can give a whole speech
on money laundering I'll talk about this
later when you guys have a question yeah
yeah used for fraud pyramid schemes all
that stuff okay so there's a global
pattern to suppress Bitcoin over the
last few years
oh by the way I sold my company I don't
know forgot if we mentioned this I sold
BTCC we sold it got acquired in January
and now I'm much more relaxed
and I'm much more free talking I can
tell you all the all the good and bad
stuff so so what I've noticed over the
last few years is that there's there's
been a global pattern from governments
and agencies around the world to
suppress Bitcoin and either it's
intentional or it's coordinated it's
hard to sell you know I don't have I
don't I don't subscribe to a lot of
conspiracy theories it's hard to tell
whether all the CIA and all the central
banks are conspiring to suppress it or
maybe they just do it out of their own
own sort of self so you see the three
monkeys you know the idea behind this
the one that can't speak the one that
can't see and the one that can't hear
it's it's more about the one that
doesn't want to speak the one that
doesn't want to see and the one that
doesn't want to hear so it's my analogy
of what the regularities they just want
to pretend bitcoins not around right but
the reality is it's too late Bitcoin was
invented it was created it was it's been
on the market for so many years it's
gained so much market value that it's
unstoppable okay so so what they're
doing is the regulating exchanges that's
a good thing I support that and also
banning banks from touching
cryptocurrencies so I guess that's
reasonable but long term I think banks
should touch it but in the short term
you see in the news more and more
countries with telling banks explicitly
do not touch Bitcoin do not process
Bitcoin transactions do not hold Bitcoin
for your customers do not advise you not
store do not hold custody of bitcoins
for your customers and so on and so
forth okay so this is very explicit the
banning I SEOs and tokens issuance or
they're creating huge regulatory sort of
complications so this happened in China
this is why this led to the whole
shutdown of BTC China last summer huge
ICO boom in China and finally the
regular says no more enough of this they
declared it illegal to fundraise via
icos
okay and it's happened in China it may
happen to more countries as well okay
showing proof of funds this is where it
gets this is where it gets to my nerves
a lot of banking transactions now ask
people to show the proof of funds right
how did you get this money the bank
account or who you're sending it to you
know all that stuff it's all this nosy
questions they
ask you this is the problem with with a
a asset system that's someone else
control when your money is actually
deposited at a bank it's actually not
your money right yeah I think I think I
can go into that later so a lot of cakes
trick to kyc processes so all the
exchanges are lifting there are
including improving the KYC
you know I told you about in seven years
ago when my co-founders were just taking
money in their personal accounts to
facility 'days are gone
okay I really mean those are good days
because I was really facilitating really
easy okay
limiting transfers limiting amounts of
transfer per day and so on and so forth
so also a lot of fun about Bitcoin
itself so there's a global effort to to
to sort of suppress Bitcoin and sort of
take people's attention away from
Bitcoin right it's rare that I get to
speak at institutions about Bitcoin but
what you hear more if people like Warren
Buffett and people openly criticizing
bitcoins value and the value of Bitcoin
okay so now the question is why do
Bitcoin prices keep going up had they
been going up yes no well in the last
three months it's been going down last
four or five months been going down but
haven't been going up so again it's
relative if you look at four months it's
been going down if you look at four
years or ten years it's been going up
why is that this is a real fundamental
do you guys know why anyone know why
Bitcoin prices keep going up anyone
curious okay and I want you to think
about this question carefully okay how
many of you and be honest okay how many
of you fundamentally think fundamentally
think and agree that Bitcoin prices will
keep going up versus the other answer
would be you think it's just a fluke
that Bitcoin price has gone up the last
eight ten years and that's gonna correct
and go back down to $10 $100 so a or B a
is you think will keep going up
all right be is it's a fluke it's just
that you know I happen to be speaking
today you might go back down to $200 in
the next three months
and anyone be in 20 years they'll go
back down to $3 yeah yeah yeah you share
a room with Warren Buffett yes okay so
so I obviously I'm with the a camp okay
and here's my answer
bitcoins value does not come from the
endorsement acceptance or regulation nor
regulation by governments okay a lot of
people mistakenly think that something
valuable has to come from the
endorsement acceptance or being
regulated by the government do you
follow me
people people have that idea I don't
subscribe to it I think bitcoins value
does not come from that rather bitcoins
value comes from the inherent failures
limitations and inconveniences of our
money system which is a fiat money
system okay so I've been in business
I've been running this company and I'm a
world traveler
I have bank accounts in other countries
and I make move money and what I've seen
personally with my own eyes and this is
and I can only say this is the
experience I've gathered in the last
four or five years running a company
before that you know I was not a
businessman I was just a salary employee
so I didn't have this perspective but
for those of you who who deal with bank
accounts moving money you may see you
may hear some of the stories I've seen
the horror of the fiat money system the
banking system everything from opening
bank accounts to declaring funds to
requesting wire transfers to checking
for for stuff like that it's it's
horrible I could that's another three
hour lecture of all the things I've seen
anyone experience that yeah okay so one
of people who do business experience it
and the rest you who didn't raise your
hand I don't blame you because for you
banking is just go to ATM sticking your
card you get $200 or using a paying
credit card at dinner you know it's very
easy but the real banking underneath is
just
you know that for that French word right
and that's why I think Bitcoin value
will go up because that system in my
opinion is gonna get worse and worse
okay for those of you who are
experienced in global finances you've
seen it get worse and worse you've seen
it how difficult it is to open bank
accounts and move money they ask they're
so nosy it's like they're asking you
like wait it's my money I want to
withdraw it right so so um anyway so so
it's it's crazy I have some yeah I don't
want to share it over there
the talk but I have some stories I was
just in Las Vegas trying to get some
cash out of the bank I'll share it I'll
share so so I'm gonna go play in the
World Series of Poker this year it's a
$10,000 buy-in in the real casino so I'm
gonna uh yes so I went to the bank to
withdraw money to go do the buy and I
withdraw $20,000 okay so I made some
money selling the company so I withdraw
20,000 now you most of you don't do it
okay so I admit
so I withdraw I asked for $20,000 I just
didn't didn't flinch I was like yeah I'm
gonna go gamble right that's that's
that's a real reason and they asked me
what are you gonna use it for I'm gonna
go to gallon they asked me what games do
I play I'm like anyways so these are are
you sure you want to take cash we can
give you a cashier's check
I'm like no I'll take cash I'll take
cash so they don't like it and then when
I go to the casino to deposit the
$10,000 should buy that that tournament
seat they asked me for my social
security number because it's a cash
transaction that hits the ten thousand
dollar mark
so all this crazy stuff I mean this is
just in the US I mean just crazy you
can't move money cash is actually the
the controlled substance now you can't
bring cash in like the $20,000 I got I
can't bring it in to the US without
declaring and I can't bring it out
without declaring the limit is ten
thousand and if you do 9,000 9,000 9,000
each time you're structuring your
movement of money and that's also
illegal under an time
seriously a lot of this is illegal now
you can't even deposit cash into someone
else's bank account seriously if I if I
owe you if I owe you five hundred
dollars I tell me your bank account
number Bank of America I go firing it
all had deposited Richard Asher's banker
they won't allow it it's a recent it's a
recent rule so a lot of issues okay so
let's keep going
okay so governments worldwide will do
actually more and more to suppress
Bitcoin because they don't like the fact
that Bitcoin is really open and free
it's really free money in the sense of
free speech okay
however the good news is that Bitcoin
was designed to survive this kind of
censorship and this kind of adverse
environment so I'm confident Bitcoin
with its decentralized nature will will
survive the decades to come okay all
right
so how to invest in Bitcoin anyone want
to invest in Bitcoin yes anyone you're
checking the time yeah you do know
Bitcoin do you hold any or do you want
to invest more you hold some you want to
invest more anyone else okay maybe I
should yeah
few more willing yes so so I'm not just
just disclosure I'm not an investment
advisor I'm not you know advising dude
that's a good point yeah so you should
you sign the waiver coming into the
class right yeah okay so here are the
mistakes to avoid here are my top four
mistakes to avoid
it may sound redundant but many people
still make these mistakes and I
certainly made all four mistakes so
here's what it is the top four mistakes
when investing in Bitcoin things to
avoid okay you ready number one
indecisiveness to make the investment
right many of you alright for me you
know 2011 when I first started mining
Bitcoin I should've just bought Bitcoin
instead of mining I should have just put
like you know week salary into it and
then I'd be a multi Multi multi
millionaire but I did not okay
so anyone indecisive yeah see a lot of
people some of you don't even know
you're doing a decisive okay second one
second one is this is key okay for those
who could actually do make the move
many of you will make the mistake of not
buying enough at first so by all y'all
invest I'll invest $13 really my friend
my good friend in Shanghai American I
was like you gotta buy it this is my
friend okay
I won't say his name he knows who he is
I'll say you gotta buy some Bitcoin you
gotta buy some Bitcoin and he's really
conservative with his investments so he
said okay I'll buy one and I sold him
one we had dinner and it's okay okay buy
one and it was like literally it's like
fifteen dollars he bought one and now
that one Bitcoin
fifteen dollars is worth you know ten
thousand dollars so he didn't he's
hitting himself for not buying enough
and his and his wife is now hitting him
for not buying it
okay the second thing a third thing is
selling after a small gain what I mean
by a small gain is not like five percent
ten percent 30 percent I mean 30 percent
is a big gain right but but but to me
thirty percent is not even a small gain
a small gain is like two hundred percent
return three hundred percent return so
there are people out there who've
purchased Bitcoin at $100 I was like you
got vibe it's only a hundred dollars
they bought it there I'm very happy and
when he gets a three hundred dollars
they sell it all they triple their money
in three months or whatever six months
very happy right yeah but in the grand
scheme I think that was the most
terrible mistake you made because if you
if you sold that three hundred now it's
at nine thousand you know so selling
don't so my point is don't sell after
small gain if you don't make 100x or at
least 20x don't solve it yeah that
that's you know not invest mine on
investment advice
and lastly it's just sell it during
panic crash so you always have panic
crashes with Bitcoin in the future
because it's human nature for to go up
to be overbought and to be oversold
right after it's over bottle come
crashing down and in the reaction is
salad
it's gloom and doom it's get over
Bitcoin is dead you know that happened
twice or three times in China it's
happened anywhere everywhere else so the
idea is to just just hold steady this is
a 20-year investment don't think about
selling it during panic crash okay all
right so thank you
follow me on Twitter but I have another
slide deck to go through and we have
some time right yeah okay so so the
reason it's how you follow me on twitter
is an inside joke is my Twitter but my
number of Twitter followers is what I
outwardly tell people that's my price
prediction for Bitcoin yeah so today
it's at about seventy five thousand
seventy four thousand followers
so the more people to follow you're
helping raise my price target yeah so it
is a self-fulfilling prophecy I admit
okay
but it's fun to see you know III start
started this back when my number fall
was only two thousand five hundred and
at the time I was ludicrous what do you
mean bitcoins gonna hit two thousand
five hundred and I said it and then hit
two thousand five and hit seven thousand
hit ten thousand it's almost hit twenty
thousand so might might follow is always
ahead of the Bitcoin price so I'm not
worried about that okay all right so
thank you very much so this is the first
half of the talk if you guys are
interested I can go and talk about more
about Bitcoin as an asset class why it's
revolutionary would you guys like that
okay the second part is pay per view
okay I'm just kidding actually I'm gonna
pay you okay we're gonna we're gonna do
the second part anyone want to get paid
today you already have your phone ready
okay all right so Bitcoin digital
currencies it's a new model of ownership
okay this is this is a modified version
of a talk I gave at TEDx Shanghai a year
ago so think about this
so let me repeat so Bitcoin and digital
currencies are actually a new model of
ownership okay so what what things you
own today
what is the ownership model today we're
gonna go over that and why is Bitcoin a
new model okay all right
what is ownership today its ownership by
title what that means is the things you
own especially the more valuable things
it's actually owned in your name and
that's a term buy owned by title
so the real estate cars you know for
those of you who own airplanes and you
know yachts same thing also bank
accounts in a mutual fund accounts the
owned by title you follow me is that a
good thing yeah of course the more the
more I own you know for rich people like
Warren Buffett Bill Gates it's all owned
by title stocks and all that stuff owned
by title nothing wrong with that or at
least not until you you listen to me
speak nothing wrong with that by
definition it's tie to identity right
owned by title it's tight your name
that's why even if I do a legal name
change
wait that's not the right analogy okay
but the point is it's tied to identity
birthday and all that so my point is the
real Warren Buffett can get access to
his bank accounts and the money inside
but I can't because I don't look like
Warren Buffett I don't have the same
name and so on okay so the past it turns
out it did not always used to be that
way in the old days ownership was by
physical possession right this is before
the the the so called current forms of
government the more mature government in
the old days in the really old days it
was physical possession whether it's
gold bars or you know a basket or a vase
or a jug of wine you know a satchel of
rice and stuff like that or your your
farm goods you know so all owned by
physical possession but what's the
problem with ownership by physical
possession it turns out you can only
hold so much right whether the clothes
or the eyeglasses or the jewelry you can
only hold so much
you put them at home and you can only
guard you can only have safekeeping of a
certain size and that's why real estate
that's why in the old days it was
castles and guards and knights and armor
and and you know stuff like that right
people guarding physical real estate
right so those are the medieval days so
it didn't scale okay that's why now you
have government and title and you have
law enforcement to help enforce it okay
today's finance financial system is also
owned by identity right we talked about
that already
credit cards bank accounts you know even
PayPal WeChat pay Ali pay and all that
stuff even digital goods even digital
counter or by identity think about like
airline miles right if you have
Southwest United airline you have mile
mile accumulating miles credit card war
points all those digital assets
so-called crypto or non crypto those are
all virtual virtual gift tokens and
stuff like that they're all tied to
identity you follow me okay what's wrong
with identity based ownership anything
wrong with that
here's what here's my spiel okay it
turns out by definition and this this
may take a little bit thinking on your
part okay to realize this anything that
you own by title by name is actually not
yours it's actually under third-party
control meaning that if they wanted to
then being the third party can muck with
it can tweak it can confiscate it can
assess charges okay can assess liens and
prevent you from selling it or
transferring it take it take SS fees and
so on so forth okay thinking just
complicated by the court of law so the
car is your own we could be confiscated
the bank accounts that could be frozen
your real estate can be have a lien on
it you can't sell it right so that's the
insight that even I did not realize
until just recently
when I got into the Bitcoin industry I
did not realize the notion that identity
based tied
ownership actually is not at my mercy is
that someone else's mercy okay
the slide folder here is a line showing
people lining up to get money from the
Bank of Cyprus and this was in April of
2013 what happened
that was when Cyprus went had a budget
crisis and the powers that be the
government legislators said hey we can
balance our books how are we gonna find
the extra money we do we can't we've
already taxed the hell out of all the
people how do you how to get more income
you know what they thought why don't we
just dip into the bank accounts of our
citizens that's what they did they they
announced they're gonna take a haircut a
haircut
sounds like a haircut but it's a real
big haircut it's like 10 20 percent
haircut for all account holders in
Cyprus bank accounts over a hundred
thousand euros they're like if they have
a hundred thousand euros they're rich
they won't they won't mind right so if
you have over a hundred thousand euros
at the time you actually got a haircut
that was a proposal and that's when all
hell broke loose people lined up and get
their money out of the banks because
they can actually do that okay so the
final solution they night they asked a
lot of back and forth they dad can do
this what they did was they actually
stuffed these banks are going bankrupt
right so so they stuffed the distressed
Bank equity to the account holders they
forced them to take in exchange for the
cyprus euros so this made Cyprus euros
less valuable than German euros so it's
really really awkward situation back
then okay so your money's actually your
your money is actually not your money so
we're talking about the bank case but
even the physical case even the paper
bills your money is actually not your
money and the reason is the value is
actually endorsed by the government so
they could withdraw at any time okay so
the oldest days it was you know the
German mark during the world war days
you know those old marks Deutsche marks
were just you know they just rendered
useless right after the war
and of course more recently will be the
Zimbabwe dollar in the late 1990s and
early 2000 the Zimbabwe dollar with the
hyperinflation eventually saw a paper
note 100 billion and that can only buy
you like three eggs you know the largest
is like a hundred trillion note I mean
those are they sell on eBay now for some
few dollars but literally you just
inflated out so you have cart bells with
money okay and more recently and this is
not I mean these are you know I mean
Zimbabwe I guess we anyone from Zimbabwe
but but even more recently real you know
countries like Venezuela the ball of are
the one in jabal of our got cancelled I
think this was in 2016 and late 2016 the
Indian rupee notes the 500 or 1000 notes
got canceled right some of you anyone
from India you remember that and to me
that's fraud to me that's like what you
know there was a mad rush to exchange
these money because the government can
arbitrarily cancel it so so you know are
these you know these are you could say
all these are just you know backward
countries or whatever but but that's not
true even even g20 countries even first
world countries are canceling banknotes
you may not know this but the British
Pound actually got canceled the
five-pound note the paper version got
canceled last year in exchange for the
newer polymer-based and the 10 pounds
gonna face the same thing in China there
I mean me got canceled the old issuer
maybe got canceled u.s. is one of the
rare countries where they don't
officially canceled the old notes but if
you actually hold on to them you're
literally the money in it is just
evaporated right so it's happened in in
you know Britain Britain Germany India
you know Venezuela is in mably these are
just examples it's happening all over
the world they can just cancel notes
arbitrarily
many of you have seen you know what I'm
talking about so money your money's not
your money so so what's next so the
evolution is the next phase is not
ownership by physical possession it's
not for ownership by identity but it's a
new thing ownership by information
what I mean here is this okay
it's information assets all right you
guys ready and of course I'm talking
about Bitcoin right Bitcoin digital
currencies true digital asset is where
the asset itself is digital and that's
what it is Bitcoin the asset is is you
know it's not just seeing it on a couple
web web page on a screen on a computer
or a tablet that's not what's digital
about it the nature of it is digital
okay
the private keys I'm talking about okay
so it's ownership by information this
yields to digital assets all right
Bitcoin 2009 invented it's the brand
okay I guess yeah I'll go to next slide
it's a brand new digital asset it has
few features let me go through them it's
limited to 21 million you guys all know
this right 21 million maximum okay it's
based on information in mathematics we
trust that yes one plus one equals two I
trust that okay borderless global we
talked about that because it's truly
borders global it's not identity based
meaning a Bitcoin account holder is not
the account holder because their name is
Bobby Lee or whoever rather it's because
of the passcode the the passphrase the
secret key the private key of that
account address okay and because it's
not identity based there is no third
party there is no one person to say this
but let me let me come back to that I
want to make another point of identity
based the issue with identity based
ownership is that someone makes a
judgment whether you are who you are
these days some banks require two forms
of ID when you walk up to the teller
have you heard of that yes everyone is
well I walk to a bank without two forms
of ID
they're like sorry you can't withdraw
money or you can't do a transaction
because you have to show me two forms ID
but I'm the guy like this is my money I
know it I know it this is my account but
the teller says nope not good enough
right so so that's it that's a prime
example of where I am the real person
this is not fraud I know I am Who I am
yet they won't let me do it because
they're the ultimate judge they keep my
money safe for me
the guy who's complaining right there
stories like where what happened
I withdrew some let's see when was this
yeah so the daily limits for atm
you know maybe five hundred dollars and
I asked you increase it you know I go to
Las Vegas you know me the gambler yeah
the secret is out so I asked him Creuset
and they say Oh 1,500 maximum now for a
lot of people 1,500 a lot of money I
agree it's a lot of money right you
certainly can't spend it all you don't
want to give a lot away but if it's my
money and I want to withdraw more than a
thousand five hundred they won't let me
do it and their theory is to protect me
so that there's no fraudulent so but
what if I say hey I accept that risk
because I I've never lost a bank card
I've never lost revealed my pin code
we've never had identity theft or any
sort of fraud with my debit card yet
they say for your own good
we're not gonna increase it for more
than that so that that's an example
prime example of why why your money is
not your money
so no third parties okay so that's the
beauty about Bitcoin okay here we go
you guys ready so in the end Bitcoin is
about ones and zeroes there's all my
digital stuff meaning that for the first
time now you can move money with yours
information so with in the old days of
physical possession I have to move stuff
I have to give you the chunk of gold
right give you the the assets if I have
you know three chickens I tie them up
and I give it to you but you have to
come meet me here in the days of title
transfer or if you buy a home sell a
home by a car sell a car you don't have
to I mean you have to deliver the car
but the home you don't deliver right the
home stays wherever it is what do you do
well you go to the third party title
registrar and say okay now we're signing
over the real estate has been sold you
show them a purchase document they you
know sign off you pay taxes and all that
but always involves a third party so the
new model of evolution the new evolution
of ownership is that now you send money
by giving information so I've just given
you a lot of money here please maybe
that's the private key okay not exactly
that but the point is with Bitcoin with
with just digital assets with
information I can send you money just by
blinking these are banks you in Morse
code that might be my private key or I
could just give you information but on a
business card or just by saying you a
secret phrase a secret word and that's
giving money to each other so that's a
true freedom of moving money when you
can just move money by to people
conversing freedom of speech you know
whether it's in person or online or
through iMessage or through whatever
communications protocol okay so I'll
give an example this is a Bitcoin
account okay so the account number is
that you know you I don't intend you to
see it it's it's that strings 1 n 2 1 w
II that an uppercase lowercase and this
is the QR code representation okay
that's the account number have you guys
so so many I assume many of you have not
seen a real Bitcoin account right is
that right so this is an example of a
real Bitcoin account and what's amazing
is this account is not tied to me or my
name or so on it's actually just tied to
this private key ok so the private key
is over here it's is this thing here
it's much longer its alphanumeric has
numbers and letters uppercase lowercase
and that's a QR code it's a bigger code
because there's more information here so
this is it whoever knows this has access
to this account is that beautiful all
right clearly not a lot of computer
science people here
it's beautiful this is this pure nature
beauty okay so that's the password this
is the account number there's a password
and they're tied together and in fact
how many people have access to this
account
well every one of me if you're taking a
photo you know everyone has access to it
down it's a it's a joint account and
they it's a communal account okay
so that's why feel free to take pictures
of this QR code and when you do buy
Bitcoin you send all your bitcoins over
here and then you're literally sharing
with the community because whoever has
this code can just withdraw the money
all right so before this class I
actually put in a hundred dollars into
this account yes I sent one hundred US
dollars worth of Bitcoin to this account
and if you are savvy enough and you want
to go ahead and pull it out no seriously
so I'll give you a few minutes you want
to take more photos or should we move on
and by the way I've given this talk many
times around the world and in the early
days because pickle was cheaper I've
given out over thousands of dollars just
through this account go check the
blockchain you'll see it ok you guys
ready anyone get it yet no one's gotten
it okay next time too bad okay so uh so
the evolution of ownership did I hear
you okay evolution ownership this is
summary okay from physical based to
identity to information okay so when
it's information that's guy that's why
this guy sort of off the off the cliff
but you know it's did you know so
there's no there's no falling anymore
okay all right so thank you very much
that's my that's the end of my prepared
remarks we'll do some Q&A okay good
yeah we have yeah we have some time
goodnight perfect so can I ask you a
question kind of about the situation
why were the regulator's in China so
worried about the icos yes the the eye
seals was particularly worrisome because
China
the form of government they want
stability above everything okay
stability of society and you know when I
CEO fundraising gets crazy anyone can do
nice anyone can raise money it's just a
matter of convincing you know the sheep
and the followers to give you money and
becomes a form of illegal fundraising
because you your fundraising basically
it's just snake oil salesmen or whatever
it whatever expression is right and so
it was getting out of control so so they
just put a hard clamp
no I SEOs no token issuance okay so
that's a fundamental reason why okay so
and then do the projects behind it but
just idea that those is just on you know
and so people who are unqualified to buy
into early-stage high-risk investments
we're doing it yeah exactly people would
give speeches give to have conferences
and say hey look at Bitcoin went up 200
times in the last number of years by
this ICO it's going to go up 200 times
in the next few years yes so much safer
to be an accredited investor here and
have to sign in so your accredited your
name yeah yeah why don't we open the
floor where do we start over here with
you at Stanford we cannot endorse any
commercial product okay we'll do it
we'll do it finally yeah yeah okay no
thank you for the reminder that's good
good good policy your tokens in
something like coin base is it similar
to keeping it in the bank in Europe yeah
so I so you know how I made a whole
spiel about no third parties and all
that stuff and I admit openly this is
something very hypocritical of me when
running the our company BTC China as an
exchange BTCC and also things like
coinbase another we're actually a hosted
service provider will horse and wallet
meaning that we actually hold your coin
for you when you deposit under my
platform so in some sense what we did
was the opposite of what I was
advocating we were actually the
third-party counterparty risk for you
right so I want you guys to be all of
you to be very aware of that when you
put your digital assets digital
currencies bitcoin is theorem like coin
when you put it on another person or
another company's platform or even if
you asked me as a friend to store it for
you it's a third party counterparty risk
so the general answer is don't do it
because bees didn't tense know better
than you know that's why people you know
if you lost money on long empty GOx is
because people trusted it put money on
insta and when mt.gox failed you
know they took all your your money just
was gone disappeared so um you know so
the good thing about the thing about
fiat money and banks is that you put
your money in the banks and they have
control but if you take it out they
still have control because they can't
answer a bank notes you see at the point
where as Bitcoin you could put on the
platform if you trust it or we could
take it out you can store yourself and
you're trusting yourself to do it so
that's a recommender approach let's move
on why don't we jump over to here yep
what about the future of the exchange
yeah yeah the so the exchange business
is very hard to run so I've experienced
it we ran one of the world's longest
running Bitcoin exchanges for many years
and I can tell you firsthand it's very
difficult job so we got it just just all
that stuff the KYC the regulation stuff
the risks the fraud the anti-fraud it's
just it's just it's just a hairy
nightmare so so when the offer came to
selves exchange after we had to shut
down you know okay all right you want to
buy it ticket
okay it wasn't that it wasn't like that
but but I sort of exaggerated there yeah
but but it was it was a good it was it
was a good decision the buyer I really
wanted it the seller was like okay this
might be the right time can I take the
second part of that question do you
think the exchange business is going to
turn out more like stock exchanges where
you only need a handful in the whole
world or is it going to be more like a
bank business where you have a handful
in each city it's gonna be the bank
business but it's actually in the middle
you can need an exchange in every
country because every country has their
own fiat money system I don't care if
it's euro as in Bob way dollars or
whatever so every country that has its
own currency will need an exchange in
that market to facility people to go on
and off the Bitcoin digital currency
rail yeah you pick the hands I want to
student go ahead yeah
so you talked a lot about Bitcoin
tillich I know but apparently China is
like the leader and blockchain patent
watching patents watching patents
oh yeah yeah okay good great topic
blockchain I'm gonna give you my an
edited sort of response on this okay I
didn't it's it's an opinion I'm in
formulated so I don't have slides
presented yet but I'm gonna work on that
here's my take Bachchan is very hot
right
you've heard about blockchain for real
estate blog for real estate I chose bar
chain for supply chain you know source
of goods bar chain for this and that box
chain for everything I'm not so hot
about blockchain please I still
fundamentally I'm a Bitcoin maximalist
I'm a I'm a classic Bitcoin you know
conservative Bitcoin person so I still
and I openly tell people the one and
only killer use case for a blockchain
today is Bitcoin and crypto currencies
but not for all the other stuff and and
if you may if we may spend five minutes
on this okay I'm gonna give a mini
lecture at the end blockchain the
conclusion is this blockchain is only
good for digital information blockchain
will never work
when relating to physical when reading
the physical world okay
people say boxing is great because it
has public data it's immutable it's a
public record decentralized no one
controls it but it's there forever you
cannot modify it that's a thought you've
heard these right but what people forget
to tell you is for information to be put
in the blockchain there's only two kinds
of information information that are so
low source and information that is
probably recognized so if I asked
virture what did you have for breakfast
today would you mind answering what do
you have bacon and eggs bacon and eggs
so he put that in the box chain does
that really mean Richard actually had
bacon and eggs for breakfast on May
first there's no truth to it because
what it really means was Richard brought
into a boxing that he had bacon eggs for
breakfast on May 1st it may not be that
yeah he made it had two breakfasts he
may have skipped breakfast he may just
made up the answer my point is even like
supply chain you know they talk about
all source of goods like oh the lettuce
was grown in Virginia by the farmer
Johnson you know and the farmer Johnson
brought into boxing I grew this lettuce
you know on on April 30th and it got
shipped by this carrier and arrived in
this supermarkets or a safe way and got
sold you have this blockchain tracking
of all that but all depends on the
person riding in right it's not publicly
verifiable information did you follow me
so with Bitcoin what's interesting is
when I if I have a hundred bitcoins and
I would send three bitcoins to Richard
would you like that oh okay you know
what the blockchain does it does three
things number one is it doesn't math if
first checks does my account or it won't
even be Bobby saying I'll give you some
account a me see account does it have a
hundred bitcoins well according to the
past history it has on your bitcoins and
then it says it doesn't matter one
hundred minus three is 97 so now after
the transaction you'll have 97 and then
Richards account might be brand-new
it'll be zero plus three equals three so
so that's where all the Bitcoin miners
out there all they have to do is compute
three things they verify my origins the
sender account has 100 bitcoins they
verified that the receiver account is a
legitimate count so you do the
subtraction
atomically in one transaction and most
importantly the third item is that the
sender actually used a private key of
the sender account to sign the
transaction so mathematical proof that
the sender authorized it and not the
receiver authorized it you follow me so
this transaction can be verified and
double-checked by anyone in the world
with a computer you don't have to be the
sender or someone someone special
privileged to do that but with when you
thought about blockchain for special
transactions with the physical world
whether I that's I sell you a house no I
sell you that condo or house I said the
house okay I move it on the boxing to
him what if the barking says it does it
really mean
it's his is there recourse is there a
source of truth does the palo alto city
government or the santa clara county
registrar do they are they the ultimate
arbitrage arbitrator rather are they the
ultimate arbitrator of whether this
property was sold right because if they
hold the master key then you'll need the
bar chain does that make sense
if the if the real estate title deeds
were done on the bar chain then there's
no master key unless you're talking
about an Oracle database blockchain you
know or my sequel database watching in
which case well that's just a database
that's not a blockchain yeah so that's
my take so I'm actually against or it's
sort of what's a word I'm not I'm not
happy with all the crazy iterations of
blockchain for the world there's a lot
of crazy stuff that's ideas that I think
are wacko that that should not be funded
but hey you know okay one more question
I saw your hand go ahead between like
holding one and going because it's gonna
run it like you said like a fabulous
display is a holding right you said in
say my people are mostly
because uh that's a graduation right
training and investing yes go like
they're making fungible so it's you know
people can trade it and so I'm like if
everybody Scooby you know you can order
you take em to what do you think sure I
I didn't even send your question number
one let's let's come back there's a
tension between like attention it
everybody's holding like okay but it's
not let me if I said let me just operate
in the market
yeah and I'm probably gonna have to stop
with that one okay okay so there is no
it's it's a false when you say there's a
challenge between holding Bitcoin and
transacting it's actually false it's a
false worry they're by definition you
know every moment in time everyone's
holding Bitcoin because the Bitcoin
because between the blocks between the
transactions the bitcoins are staying
put and then when that when it moves
every ten minutes they move and then
they stay put does that make sense so so
forever you will always have accounts
that are just dormant that the Bitcoin
just stay there for days for weeks for
months for years there's been Bitcoin
accounts that have been dormant for
years right and then there are accounts
have moved really fast so the world
that's how the world is it's just like
real estate in Palo Alto right if you
try to buy you can always buy a home in
Palo Alto but there are homes that been
you know to the same older for the last
four years that have not just been sold
so the fact that people sit in their
homes in Palo Alto and they don't sell
it doesn't mean that there's no home
available for sale because at the right
price someone will say aha
I've made enough I'm gonna sell it does
that make sense so that's what I observe
so I don't see it as a natural natural
challenge between the holders and the
traders and the transaction people okay
so the next question is good so what if
your question is what if China tomorrow
this had allowed Bitcoin that would be
that would be a world-shaking event
that'll be history in the making
especially after if they did it after
you asked a question they'll be really
I I think it will happen I think it will
happen I think nothing in this world is
permanent especially a country like
China a very different government style
even the one-child policy which was in
place for decades finally went away last
year last two years right so Caprican
Jo's going to go away in China the
one-child policy has already gone away a
lot of rules will change right Bitcoin
whether it's officially allowed not
allowed I think they will change
I think wishing and here's why I'll end
on this note Bitcoin in the end is
actually about freedom and I didn't
realize this until I got into this
industry like like when I embarked on
this journey it wasn't a political thing
it was an ideology thing it was just
because cool technology you know it was
cool I got into it but but having been
in it for five six seven years now I've
realized that Bitcoin represents freedom
and I mean freedom with a capital F with
the real freedom that America is
supposed to have right do we have it
yeah okay so America has it it's that
freedom why because in the end we have
freedom of speech we have freedom of pre
freedom protest freedom of what that's
freedom assembly that's right phrase you
have all sorts of freedom civil rights
and all sorts of stuff in America that's
great I really love the country I'm a US
citizen I'm an immigrant so I became a
US citizen so I'm really thankful for
America giving me opportunity that's how
I got into Stanford and all that stuff
so in the end Bitcoin is about freedom
because that it's almost like the LAT
what are the last one to to freedom to
own something truly own something now
this thing happens just be a password a
passphrase like a QR code but if you are
the owner knows it and your revealation
anyone else that's that's what it is you
know even if they torture you you could
you could pretend I don't forgot in fact
when did you torture you've probably
already forgotten so so the point is
this possible deniability right so so
that's a true freedom that I did that I
can give you something without anyone in
the world finding their business right I
can just give you whether it's a
handshake or a piece of American Pie
or or a frakkin they call I gave out
$100 with a Bitcoin I hope what have you
got it I don't know if you've already
anyone confirmed anyone here no okay
well go back you sell find you dollars
so I always able to give that to you
we thought the IRS on my back will see
but but really I was able to give it to
you without asking permission from the
CEO of Wells Fargo Bank or the or the
teller at Bank of America or the Federal
Reserve now it's just a hundred dollars
but it could have easily been two
million dollars right if you gave me the
budget you see my point if I gave out a
million dollars here just like that
would it be illegal well I hope not
because we're in America because it's
its freedom information it's freedom of
speech right it's a form of speech right
literally I showed it on the slide it's
my presentation it's a form of speech it
just happens to be a private teacher an
account that had a million dollars on it
was that money laundering well that's
where the money long animals are a
little bit crazy so fundamentally you
know probably none of you are very truly
libertarian at heart you know I wasn't
but after learning about this I liked it
I think I think this is this is how I
want my world to be out how I want my
government to be to allow me to own
assets on my own free wall because I had
that technology prowess to manage the
private keys and I don't need someone
else to do it for me I don't need a
banker I don't need to tell her I don't
need a company to tell me what I can do
and cannot do with my own money in the
end it's my money right so you know
Bobby I think that's a great point to
end our formal session on we've got
refreshments outside let's do all of our
discussion outside okay clear the room
but if you would please thank Bobby here
okay
[Applause]
you